let's talk about data visualization so
that we can avoid problems like this
which is where we've got some kind of
graph who knows what it means loads and
loads of lines none of them labeled I
think the thick one is more important
that's that's what I've learned from
this data visualization is another
method we can use along with statistics
to have a look at our data Explorer our
data and try and work out what's going
on it's a way of trying to understand
our data better so that we can then
perform you know more rigorous
statistical tests or actually start to
draw conclusions or model our data it's
a very important tool but you've got to
use it properly you can't just plot
anything and everything every chart you
use has got to support your hypothesis
or it's got to try and show the story
you're trying to tell right you don't
just plot something because it could be
plotted there's got to be a point to it
there's a lot of problems with using
inappropriate grass and only picking
subsets of your data that's a huge
problem right that is not just a problem
for data visualization that's a problem
for your statistical test as well if
you're only using some of your data
it's that okay it's going to depend on
the situation right my um you know but I
think there's a strong argument for
saying you've got to be really really
careful and you've got to be really
structured and regimented and document
everything you do
the core problem with visualization is
that people just plot stuff and they do
it badly maybe they use the
inappropriate plot type or they don't
scale of axes properly and that leads to
huge misunderstandings and actually can
be quite misleading right this happens a
lot in the media so for example you
might get a sort of political message
for your door but says these are
different parties so this is party one
this is party to this is party three and
maybe you know party one's got this many
votes and party twos got this many votes
and party three two right down here and
party two are trying to make the case
that just a few more votes and they're
gonna win in this area why but actually
written down here this is twenty
thousand and this is ten thousand and
this is you know eight thousand and just
in the small labeling they've got here
they've completely skewed the axis right
ten thousand is half of twenty thousand
yet here we are up here if you misuse
plots it's actually misleading when it's
on your own data you're going to draw
the wrong conclusions and then spend
quite a while researching into an area
but doesn't make sense or and ends up in
failure or if it's if it's something
you're presented to someone else you can
mislead that person whether
intentionally or by accident
and that's never a good thing I'm back
in our and I just wanted to show a
couple of plots that you know it's not
misleading necessarily but you can
easily infer the wrong kind of
information right so there's this
websites online you can go to to look at
the ratings for different TV shows right
now one of my favorite TV shows is
Fraser right I think it's amazing and if
you go on to these sites and you plot
the ratings for all these Fraser
episodes it's all over the place
sometimes it's very highly regarded and
sometimes it's not so I'm just going to
plot this using the GG plot tool and we
can see if we look at the graph that
it's absolutely everywhere right you've
got good episodes you've got bad
episodes and it seems to maybe be going
slightly downhill towards the end but
it's difficult to say right because it's
all over the place now what's actually
happened is I've just plotted using a
default function and it's Auto scaled my
rating axis right so my y-axis is the
rating of the episodes and it's going
between seven and about nine and a half
now that isn't representative because
it's spreading out my data if I plot the
exact same data but this time from
naught to ten like an actual rating
system you can see that most episodes
get almost the exact same rating
somewhere between around seven and a
half to eight which I think's pretty
good I would rate them a 10 but you know
it's just me you can see that even if
you're not careful if you do it by
accident even auto-scaling a maxi's and
things like this can cause a real
problem another classic example you'll
see in the news is when they show
something like a currency exchange rate
so if we look at here we've got our I've
downloaded some sample data of the
Japanese yen versus the US dollar and
I've simplified this by extracting just
a period of about 60 days in the middle
of some time I can't remember exactly
what it is if we plot this you can see
that actually there's a big sort of
cliff edge something terrible has
happened around day 30 and the value of
the Japanese yen is just plummeting and
of course this is absolute nonsense
right because this scale goes between
108 and a hundred and fourteen and so if
we plot it with a proper axes on you can
see that actually it's almost completely
flat if your business relies on the
exchange rate of a Japanese yen to the
US dollar
obviously these small changes might be
important right but if you're presenting
this in the news it's very easy to claim
that something terrible's happened when
in fact actually maybe this is just
normal blip
up and down right so you can misuse
plots to serve your purpose right or and
you can do it accidentally and waste a
huge amount of time let's have a look at
the standard plots you might see right
and you could use on a very basic level
and see you know what are they
appropriate for right because one of the
most important things is that you use
these plots and these charts
appropriately alright so you know
perhaps the most common one that
everyone sees is going to be a bar chart
you've got two axes you've got some kind
of attributes or labels down here and
then you've got some quantity or amount
of some attribute here and then you're
going to have different bars like this
now this is a very nice graph to use
it's simple but it's effective because
you can very easily see what the
difference between these different
levels are right so that you know it's
often going to be your go to graph for
lots of things right some people now
some people try and replace this graph
of a pie chart right this is a bad idea
in general I mean I like pie as much as
the next person but if you've got
different things like this and one of
them is big I mean you can see that this
one's bigger than this one
but how much bigger it is I don't know
you can't see the relative sizes quite
so easily this all gets worse if you
combine this into a doughnut plot and
then you've got multiple pies embedded
in each other
none of them align and nothing makes any
sense anymore right so if in doubt don't
use a pie chart it's a bad idea I mean
they look very nice for presentations
that's about what I can say for it if
we're going to be measuring some call of
quantity then a bar charts going to be
what we want right but what we might
also do is replace quantity with the
with the frequency or the amount of
something so this is gonna be frequency
this is also our labels again on the
bottom here we've got our labels and
this is going to be bins for some single
attribute so this is maybe so naught to
10 that misses maybe 10 to 20 of
whatever the thing is and this is a
frequency the amount that fall into that
range and what this allows us to do is
work out very easily what the
distribution is is it normally
distributed but I'm only distributed
with two peaks you know is it suitable
left skewed to the right we can see very
easily the shape of our data and it can
be really helpful another way of looking
at this sort of the shape or the range
of our data in particular is a box plot
right now you'll see box plots come up
from time to time with scientific
documents but they're very easy to
produce in tools like are and they can
be quite
useful so here we're gonna have a single
attribute so some label again or some
attribute here and this is going to be
the quantity of this attribute and what
a boxplot does is label the range of
that data so we're going to have a box
here like this and it's going to look a
little bit like this so I'll use a
different color pen this line in the
center is our median typically and then
this is going to be the third quartile
here third quartile and this is going to
be the first quartile and then these are
the max and the min in this one plot
we've got the absolute range of our data
we've got where 50% of our data is sort
of this interquartile range here and we
know where the midpoint of our data is
so we can very easily see whether we've
got outliers and we can plot this next
to a different attribute and we can have
two box plots next to each other and we
can see very quickly you know a
comparison between these two things so
that can be really useful now the final
ones right we're going to be talking
about scatter plots and trend lines all
right so it's got to pop very simple
we've got two attributes
this is attribute one and this is
attribute two and we want to see how
they bury with respect to each other
so when one goes up does the other one
go up or does it go down are they even
related to
so you'll see something like this and
it'd be all over the place often but you
can see maybe there's a kind of trend
where as attribute one increases
attribute two increases right now this
is a correlation being shown here not a
causation so you can't say they're
definitely related but you can say that
generally speaking when one is big so is
the other that's but sometimes useful a
trendline is going to be where we're
going to be plotting something over time
my so this has to be a continuous
variable or at least a variable we
believe can be inferred between our
points like it's unlikely but you're
gonna have all the points so you what
you might have is you might have a plot
where you've got time down here so maybe
time in mumps for example and we've got
some amount of something and we're just
going to plot it like this and we can
sort of have a trendline going like this
if it's a situation where we can infer
the amount between two time points then
this is okay right because we can say
well look we've got a reading here we've
got a reading here it's reasonable to
assume that between these two points
this is the amount
all right nothing to funny's gone on
between these two points right
if you can't assume that then you
shouldn't really be using a trendline
and you probably want to be using a bar
graph
does that depend on the kind of day to
them yes it'll depend on it this is a
judgment call based on the kind of data
so if a data I mean time is a good good
example we don't tend to measure sort of
in infinitely small increments we're
going to be measuring daily or hourly or
something like this but we can kind of
make an assumption a lot of the time
that our readings like temperature for
example over time if you're at 20 and
then the next hour you're at 25
we're probably halfway between there to
between those two times right it's going
to depend on your data I mean a good
example would be if you were plotting
something like operating system usage
per student so we've got OS X here but
Linux here and we've got Windows these
many people use OS X this many people
uses Linux this many people use Windows
well bees have discrete data points you
can't fit a trend line to these there is
no operating system that's 50% between
Linux and Windows that I know of and we
can't infer how many students are going
to be using it that makes no sense
that should be a bar chart so let's look
at an actual data set and see how we can
use some of this visualization in
practice so I've got here a chicken data
set and this data set is about weighing
chickens on different diets over a
period of weeks and also measuring how
many eggs they produced I'm not a farmer
but let's imagine that what we wanted to
do was see if one of these diets
produces a better weight gain and maybe
more eggs per week let's have a look so
I'm going to load the chicken data set
this is at stored in a CSV just like
before let's have a quick look at just
the first few rows of this data to see
what they look like so that's going to
be the head function and we you can see
we've got six attributes so we've got
the week but the measurement was taken
the chicken in this case of chicken
number one but they'll obviously be
other chickens diet they're on a diet B
or diet see the age of the chicken in
mumps the weight of a chicken in
kilograms and the number of eggs they
produce that week all right so there's
going to be lots of combinations of
weeks and chickens in this data set now
what we want to try and do is see if
there's any kind of relationship between
the diet they're on and the number of
eggs they're producing or the weight of
a chicken or anything like this so the
first thing we could do is we could have
a look at the aggregate function so I'm
going to paste this down here we'll talk
through it what the aggregate function
does is let us produce let's say a
summary or calculate some means or
medians over a data set but this time
grouping by a certain attribute so in
this case what we're going to do is
we're going to aggregate the weight of
the chickens bar in groups of their diet
so all the A's all the B's and all the
C's and then we're gonna for each of
those we're going to calculate a summary
so let's run that and you can see that
we've got our group down here for a
we've got the minimum the maximum the
median the mean and we can see some
slight differences perhaps in these data
sets I mean the median mean for example
of Group A it's 3.8 whereas the mean for
Group C is 3.4 so maybe there's a slight
difference in these things okay so let's
try a different aggregate function so
this time we're going to aggregate the
number of eggs produced
groups by again the diet so this is
going to be all the A's
all the B's and all the Seas and then
we're going to produce a summary so we
can see that the median number of eggs
produced for group a is 4 per week and
for group B and Group C is 3 per week so
maybe again there's a slight difference
we're starting to learn a little bit
about our data so let's start with
histogram light so what we're gonna do
we're gonna use this histogram function
which is mostly labels like the hist
function in our produces a histogram and
we're going to produce a histogram of
the ages of a chickens so what's the
distribution of the ages are they old
are they young and we're gonna use 15
breaks that means we're going to take
the whole range and break it into 15
columns 15 bands right now actually I
will do a little bit of just a few
checks behind the scenes to make sure 15
is an appropriate number and might
adjust it up or down slightly so we can
see this histogram broadly speaking our
chickens are evenly distributed among
the different ages we've got some young
ones that sort of 60 or 70 weeks old
older ones that are 350 weeks old and
then for some reason we've got a peak
around 250 I don't know why that is but
I maybe we've got a batch of a certain
age of chickens in and let's finally
let's look at the box plot so we talked
about the block's plot box plot will
tell us the minimum the maximum for an
attribute and also the median in the
range right so this is really helpful so
we're just going to have a look just to
age just for all chickens so you can see
that the median is around 220 something
like that and then the majority of the
chickens so 50% of the chickens fall
between about 150 weeks old and 300
weeks old but you can see there are some
very young ones and some very old ones
this kind of plot will end it's really
size up where our data sits before we
start to make any assumptions so let's
imagine now that we want
to try and drill down into his day to a
bit and work out whether actually the
diet had any effect on the number of
eggs or the weight of a chicken right so
what we're going to do is we're going to
group we're going to use the aggregate
function again to calculate the means of
all the weights per week I was going to
copy that down here so we're going to
say aggregate the weight of the chickens
by both the week and the diet so
combinations a week one die a week to
die a and so on and I don't want you to
calculate the mean for all chickens so
run that so that produces some
statistics on the different average
weight of chickens over time I'm going
to rename the columns so that they're a
little bit more informative that sort of
run that line there and then finally
we're going to plot this now we're going
to use GG plot for this you know whether
you use the inbuilt our plot functions
or enough alive we like GG plot will
kind of depend on what plot you want to
do in general you can get quite nice
plots with GG plot but they're a little
bit more involved
alright so I'm going to run this line
here looking at this data we can kind of
see that maybe da a is having a positive
effect right so down at the bottom where
no weeks are passed at the beginning of
our experiment there were roughly the
same weight and then the average weight
of a actually does seem to increase so I
guess that's something interesting about
our data right now let's look at number
of eggs right so we're gonna do the same
thing this time we're going to aggregate
the number of eggs by week and by diet
so they don't copy that and I'm going to
give it some helpful labels as well and
then we're going to put the data let's
see over time whether or not any of the
diets have any effect on the eggs and
it's looking pretty good alright so this
is the frequency as the number of eggs
were producing the weeks is the twelve
weeks of our experiment and you can see
that diet B and IC produce roughly the
same number of eggs per week
this is averaged over all the chickens
but diet a produces at least an egg more
per week on average you know that's a
20% increase roughly speaking if you're
if you're a farmer that's a great thing
but the problem we've got is that this
might be a little bit too good to be
true what we're seeing here is perhaps
an issue of correlation versus causation
so we can see here that there is a
correlation between the diet that's
being used and the number of eggs but we
don't know but it's the diet
specifically that causes it we're
looking more detail at the ages of the
chickens specifically because I'm
interested to know him whether or not
Paul older chickens produce more or
fewer eggs right because that could be
relevant to our to our experiment okay
so we're going to group the chickens up
by diet and then work out what their
average age is so mean age so I'm going
to calculate this on this here and then
I'm going to look at it and we can see
that the average age the mean age for
Group A or these chickens on diet a is
only 156 weeks but the age for let's say
Group C is 248 weeks are significantly
older all right so we need to just check
that this isn't going to be an issue for
the number of eggs laid so let's plot
the number of eggs versus the age of the
chickens right so here we're going to
generate a scatterplot of age versus the
number of eggs but we're also going to
color by diet so we can see roughly
where the different diets sits let's run
this okay so what we can see is but
actually as chickens get older we do see
a quite serious decrease in the number
of eggs produced per week from about
four and a half hour wage down to about
two and a half or two average right and
also we can see that IAE is
predominately sitting up here which
means that the chickens are younger so
this could be a problem what we're
saying is that it could be that we
happen to have put a load of young
chickens on diet a and yes they're
producing more eggs but that isn't
because of die a that's because they're
younger right so let's have a look at a
box plot of the age of chickens per diet
and you can see that they're
significantly younger on diet a so I
think the conclusion we can draw is but
it's theoretically possible that there's
a link between the diet and the number
of eggs produced but we can't really say
it from this data we're going to need a
lot more data maybe some you know some
more chickens I like to try and work
this out we've seen a number of
different visualizations and the
important thing is that we use
visualizations appropriately and we
don't make assumptions about our data so
we're going to start to look at cleaning
of data and then maybe using our data in
clustering and classification but
visualization is a really good way to
start off exploring your data and
generate some initial hypotheses
well we're looking at chocolate datasets
today so I thought I'd bring some
research yeah good and definitely
relevant